on est assez ainsi décidé
mes chers collègues
mes chers
du chantier de restauration de la
cathédrale Notre-Dame nous accueillons
le général Jean-Louis georgeslin
président de l'établissement public
chargé de la conservation de la
restauration de la cathédrale
si vous pouvez faire un peu de silence
merci
vous voyez vous voyez j'ai si votre
présence c'est votre présence en général
qui provoque ici un enthousiasme
et
au nom de l'ensemble des sénateurs de la
commission je vous remercie d'avoir une
nouvelle fois accepté notre invitation
c'est en échange avec vous sont
nécessaires afin de nous permettre de
contrôler l'application de la loi du 29
juillet 2019 que nous avons que nous
avions voté évidemment ils permettent
aussi d'apporter de la transparence sur
le fonctionnement de votre établissement
public et sur le déroulement du chantier
des roulements évidemment qui intéresse
tous les Français dans la mesure où
notre audition est captée et diffusée
sur le site du Sénat c'est la troisième
fois que nous vous recevons de votre
depuis votre prise de fonction lorsque
nous vous avions reçu en septembre 2021
la phase de restauration débitait
seulement le calendrier et le budget des
travaux restaient encore imprécis
nous avons évidemment de nombreuses
questions à vous poser mais je voudrais
commencer à me poser quelques unes
d'abord où en est-on désormais du
chantier c'est évidemment un point
important j'ai cru comprendre que le
chantier restait sous la surveillance
étroite de l'inspection du travail
la date de réouverture annoncée du 8
décembre 2024 sera-t-elle tenue
réouverture au public et puis bien sûr
quels seront les travaux qui devront
être poursuivis au-delà de de cette date
et est-ce que c'est l'établissement
public
est-ce que c'est l'établissement public
qui continuera en assurer la conduite
évidemment nous avons aussi des
questions financières à vous poser même
si nous lisons avec attention les
rapports de la Cour des comptes en la
matière
à combien devrait s'élever le montant
des travaux évidemment c'est une
enveloppe prévisionnelle tant qu'ils ne
sont pas achevés et des arbitrages se
dessinent-ils d'ores et déjà concernant
l'affectation du surplus des dons nous
avons entendu la Fondation du Patrimoine
mi-décembre et nous avons pu constater
qu'il s'agissait d'une question qui
préoccupe les organismes collecteurs
tenus de respecter évidemment les
intentions des donateurs ce qui m'amène
à ma troisième série de questions
comment se passent les relations de
l'établissement public avec ses
différents partenaires la maîtrise
d'oeuvre le ministère de la culture
ainsi que les donateurs et les
organismes collecteurs pour densité que
quelques-uns vous voyez en général nous
avons de nombreuses questions et je ne
doute pas que mes collègues dans
quelques instants en rajouteront mais
avant de
transmettre ta parole je vais évidemment
vous laisser dans un propos introductif
nous faire un point sur ce chantier
auquel nous sommes tous attachés
bien merci monsieur le Président vous
avez dit qu'il fallait contrôler la
transparence de l'établissement public
sur ce point je vous rassure la
transparence est absolument totale
nous sommes probablement l'établissement
public le plus observé le plus pesé le
plus mesuré de toute l'histoire de la
République probablement vous avez
dit que vous aviez reçu Monsieur
Poitrinal président de la
patrimoine vous avez employé le mot de
surplus je vais y revenir il n'y a pas
évidemment de surplus il y a
846 millions d'euros qui seront utilisés
pour rendre la cathédrale Notre-Dame de
Paris toute sa splendeur et tout ce
qu'elle n'aurait jamais dû cesser d'être
voilà alors je vous remercie pour
recevoir pour cette troisième audition
dont vous l'avez rappelé cette
[Musique]
cette réunion là aujourd'hui arrive à
une étape majeure du chantier alors que
à peine deux ans c'est pas grand chose
nous sépare de la réouverture vous avez
avancé la date du 8 décembre
2024 c'est l'archevêque de Paris qui a
articulé pour la première fois je crois
dans les médias cette date mais c'est
effectivement la date vers laquelle nous
nous orientons aujourd'hui donc après le
temps de la sécurisation de l'édifice
puis de la préparation de la
restauration c'est l'époque où j'étais
venu vous l'avez rappelé en septembre
2021 c'est ça je crois oui c'est ça nous
sommes maintenant complètement et
pleinement dans les travaux effectifs de
la restauration
et
l'intense l'intense activité qui règne
sur le chantier latex Notre-Dame de
Paris est vraiment en train de renaître
grâce à la mobilisation constante des
équipes de l'établissement public de la
maîtrise œuvre des entreprises que nous
avons sélectionné ces derniers mois le
chantier basse en plein conformément au
calendrier que nous avions fixé dès le
départ
le dynamisme des travaux produit ses
effets de manière très visible de
semaine en semaine la restauration des
intérieurs du monument rend d'ores et
des jeunes
la plaine beauté de ces pierres
nettoyées et l'État éclatantes de ces
décors dans les chapelles de du cœur
il témoigne de l'engagement et de la
compétence que montrent les entreprises
que nous avons sélectionnées les
compagnons les artisans d'art qui sont à
l'oeuvre dans la cathédrale et dans les
ateliers partout en France et pas
seulement sur l'île de la Cité
le bon aboutissement ça n'a pas été
mince des nombreux appels d'offres que
nous avons conduit depuis plus d'un an
près d'une centaine de marchés attribués
à ce jour la passion et la fierté il
faut souligner des compagnons que je
constate tous les jours sont les
meilleurs gages de réussite dont nous
pouvons disposer
comme je l'ai rappelé nous avons achevé
la première phase des travaux celle de
la sécurisation de la cathédrale à la
fin d'été le 21 nous l'avons achevé il
faut le noter dans le respect total du
Grand du calendrier que nous avions fixé
tout en restant en deçà en deçà de
l'enveloppe que nous avions fixée
150,3 millions d'euros pour une
enveloppe prévisionnelle de 165 millions
d'euros
cette phrase est désormais loin derrière
nous je ne reviens pas car j'ai eu
l'occasion de vous la présenter en
détail
lors de ma dernière audition en
septembre
nous sommes donc dans une phase
particulièrement active avec la
réalisation des opérations préparatoires
à la restauration
désormais achevé et le travail d'appel
d'offre de travaux afin de sélectionner
en permanence les meilleurs entreprises
alors tout d'abord la décomposition de
la phase de restauration de la
cathédrale
nous avons des composés la phase de
restauration en 5 sous opérations sur la
base de critères géographiques
calendaires et de priorité d'achèvement
c'est sous opérations sont constituées
chacune en un appel d'offres divisé en
plusieurs lots elle se répartissent de
la façon suivante la première sous
opération concerne tous les nettoyages
intérieurs de la cathédrale le
traitement des boats vitraux et
remplacent et toute la mise hors d'eau
des parties basses de la cathédrale
collatéraux déambulatoire et chapelle ce
premier appel d'offres comprend 37 lots
qui correspondent à des découpages par
corps de métier mais aussi par zone
géographique à l'intérieur de la
cathédrale et concerne de nombreux
métiers d'art vitraux peinture
ferronnerie
l'ensemble des 37 lots a été attribué
les travaux sont en cours dans la
cathédrale ou dans les ateliers de
restauration
la deuxième hautement emblématique est
consacrée à la reconstruction de la
flèche de la voûte effondrée de la
croisée du transcept et du Grand comble
du transept c'est ce qu'il y a de plus
spectaculaire et c'est ce que les gens
attendent le plus elle est décomposée en
7 lots qui sont tous attribués les
travaux sont en cours notamment
l'échafaudage qui va permettre la
reconstruction de la voûte effondrée de
la croisée du transep et la
reconstruction de la flèche
la troisième sous opération concerne le
cœur et la nef avec la restauration des
maçonneries incendiées les murs Bahus
les vous défendraient le grand comble
avec sa charpente en chêne et sa
couverture en plomb elle est décomposée
en 15 lots qui ont tous été attribués
les études d'exécution et les travaux
préparatoires en atelier sont en cours
la quatrième sous opération
moi spectaculaire mais essentiel et
consacrée aux installations techniques
de la cathédrale réseau électrique
chauffage et aux travaux
d'accompagnement architectural c'est pas
mince permettant le passage des câbles
et des réseaux elle est décomposée en 12
lots dont 8 sont attribués et dont les
quatre derniers le seront dans le
courant de l'actuel trimestre
la cinquième sous opération
s'intéressera à la restauration des
beffroi en particulier le beffroi dans
la tour nord abimée par l'incendie et
aux émanations aux aménagements liés au
parcours du public dans les tours la
consultation relative à cette sous
opération sera elle aussi lancée pendant
ce trimestre
tous ces marchés de travaux sont
complétés par une quinzaine de marchés
de prestations intellectuelles et
d'assistance indispensables aux
chantiers
notamment pour les missions d'OPC
ordonnancement pilatage coordination
CSPS coordinateur de sécurité de
protection de la santé
gardiennage économie de la construction
contrôle technique
métrologie plomb amiante sûreté sécurité
incendie bois côté incendie du chantier
enfin les installations de chantier et
de la base vide
hérité de la phase de sécurisation connu
des modifications importantes pour
s'adapter aux besoins du chantier de
restauration et permettre à la maîtrise
d'ouvrage à la maîtrise d'oeuvre et aux
entreprises de travailler dans de bonnes
conditions
il s'agit par exemple des moyens de
levage grue des magalots de chantier qui
abritent les bureaux vestiaires douche
qui joue un rôle essentiel dans ce
chantier avec le plomb vous avez dit
monsieur le Président tout à l'heure que
l'inspection du travail avait une
affection particulière pour notre
chantier et nous sommes extrêmement
respectueux du code du travail
naturellement et réfectoire
pour l'ensemble de ces consultations
lancées par l'établissement la
concurrence à jouer pleinement et tous
les lots ont pu être servis sous réserve
de l'examen des offres et des cadavules
des candidatures encore en cours que
j'ai cité tout à l'heure
ainsi la moyenne des offres reçues
s'établies à 9,5 candidats par lot pour
les marchés de prestations
intellectuelle à trois candidats par lot
pour les opérations préparatoires et à
3,1 pour les 70 marchés des sous
opérations 1 2 3 et 4 que j'ai décrit
ils ont été notifiés en 2022 et le
nombre d'offres reçues pour ces quatre
premières sous opérations s'élèvent à
238 ça vous montre le travail colossal
que notre petite établissement public
sous-dimensionné affronte
dans l'anonymat le plus total
ces résultats sont donc très
encourageants des campagnes de
communication et le surface systématique
effectués en amont des publications
des consultations ont porté leur fruit
toute l'action menée depuis l'automne
dernier dans la stricte mise en oeuvre
des principes de la commande publique
soulinera jamais que nous n'avons
strictement aucune
dérogation à quoi que ce soit dans le
goût droit commun des procédures
contrairement à nos amis italiens pour
leur pont de Gênes dans le droit commun
des procédures contractuelles mais
agissant la mise en concurrence et
l'égalité d'accès des entreprises à nos
marchés portent pleinement ces fruits
ce travail est gouverné par un objectif
calendaire ambitieux auquel nous croyons
tous
l'établissement public les maîtres
d'ouvrage les architectes en chef des
monuments historiques à CMH maître
d'oeuvre ainsi que toutes les
entreprises qui nous ont rejoint au gré
des attributions des marchés c'est au
tour de cet objectif que nous organisons
eritement tout notre travaux vous avez
rappelé cet objectif moi je ne suis là
que pour ça faire en sorte que tout le
monde et l'esprit rivé sur l'objectif de
réouverture on ne trouverez plus
personne et en cela la situation a bien
changé par rapport encore au début de
l'été dernier sur le chantier c'est à
dire sur les acteurs de ce chantier qui
remettent en cause notre capacité à
atteindre cet objectif
voilà
comme vous avez rappelé vous avez cité
le rapport de la Cour des comptes nous
avons reçu comme du miel ça magnifique
phrase les conditions semblent d'abord
sur la quitus pour la manière dont
l'établissement public fonctionne et
ensuite soulignant que les conditions
étaient réunies effectivement pour une
réouverture en 2024
voilà c'est un satisfait site complet
que nous avons reçu et ça a été encore
une fois un baume délicieux sur nos
cœurs et nos esprits
alors j'en viens maintenant aux travaux
en cours à la cathédrale alors plusieurs
avancées récentes à test que sous notre
impulsion c'est celle des architectes en
chef des monuments historiques qui
dirigent les travaux le chantier avant
avec dynamisme et franchit d'une série
de jalons concrets qui prépare la
réouverture en 2024
les maçons d'ailleurs de Pierre viennent
d'achever la reconstruction de la voûte
effondrée dans le 30 septembre
de la charpente lors de l'incendie ça a
été pour nous un moment d'une émotion
considérable lorsque nous avons posé la
dernière pierre de ce Boutin
qui était c'est le premier acte concret
si je puis dire de la reconstruction de
cette cathédrale donc ils ont utilisé
pour le faire les compagnons qui s'y
sont
attelés les échafaudages plancher et
cintre en bois mise en place lors de la
phase de sécurisation que
n'entendions-nous à cette époque et bien
tout ceci comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure préparer la moisson actuelle et
pas à pas nous reconstruisons de manière
définitive
cette reconstruction de Boutin a
nécessité l'emploi de 14 mètres cubes de
pierre
taillé et mise en œuvre sur place par
les compagnons
en même temps le remplacement des
pierres fragilisées par les hautes
températures de l'incendie et bien
avancé
cette opération est plus
particulièrement nécessaire là où
s'appuieront les futurs charpent on ne
les verra pas mais c'est ce qui va
permettre d'appuyer les futurs
charpentes c'est le cas des murs Bahus
qui se situe à la partie supérieure de
la croisée du transept au 4 angles que
nous avons achevé là où reposera la
flèche
le montage de l'échafaudage de 600
tonnes 600 tonnes nécessaires aux
travaux de construction de la voûte de
la croisée du transept et de la flèche
est achevée pour sa première phase vous
voyez qu'il prend appui sur le transcept
là où ont été conduites les fameuses
fouilles qui avaient déchaîné tous les
docteurs et tous les médias donc cette
échafaudage est arrêtée aujourd'hui à
une hauteur de 26 mètres c'est-à-dire la
hauteur maximale des piliers du transep
nous l'avons équipé d'un plancher sur
lesquels ont été posées quatre demi
cintres en bois réalisé sur mesure et
ceci et c'est assez spectaculaire et là
aussi ça nous ça nous rassure constitue
l'ossature indispensable au maçon
tailleur de pierre qui bientôt vont
reconstruire les arcs et l'oculus vous
souvenez tous de l'oculus sur lequel il
y avait la Vierge de la croisée du
temple 7 entièrement détruit par
l'incendie
les pierres de Césars qui ont été
complètement taillées dans les
ateliers de l'entreprise Lefebvre à
Gennevilliers sont arrivés sur l'île de
la Cité vendredi matin sur des barges
vous voulez que nous sommes très
respectueux de la circulation de Paris
des préceptifs des pré des prescriptions
liées au climat etc nous sommes
exemplaires dans ce domaine aussi
voilà l'échafaudage va poursuivre
ensuite quand on aura placé ces arcs sa
construction son ascension au fur et à
mesure de la construction de la flèche
que l'on commencera à avoir pointe dans
le ciel de Paris en 2023 cette année
alors vous avez compris qu'on s'est
arrêté à 26 mètres le coq là haut est à
96 mètres
il nous reste donc 70 mètres pour monter
cet échafaudage c'est un travail
colossal et de nous arrêtons pour
construire les arcs du transep et le
tabouret de la flèche qui s'appuiera sur
ses piliers
nous avons construit comme c'est l'usage
un atelier de sculpture sur le Palm be
de la cathédrale les sculpteurs sont
près des architectes sur les chantiers
médiévaux l'une c'est un dispositif
inédit permettant donc au compagnons de
travailler au plus près de la cathédrale
en toute sécurité
il accueille les premières équipes
chargées de réaliser les sculptures
neuves il y a pas des tonnes de
sculpture qui ont été détruites dans
l'incendie bien sûr donc on va remplacer
celle trop altéré ou détruite ainsi que
les quatre anges qui ornent l'anneau de
compression de la voûte du transept
appelée
oculus zenital donc la voût de la
croisée qui sont en cours de copie ceux
qui sont familiers de la cathédrale se
souviennent qu'autour de la viande il y
avait quatre anges sont tombés
par probablement l'opération du
Saint-Esprit 2 ne se sont pas fracassés
et ils ont été copiés et nous les
remettrons dans son cas de copies qui
seront là et c'est déjà taillés
en parallèle les travaux de restauration
antérieure
continue leur progression il mobilise de
nombreux artisans et à l'hotelier d'art
le nettoyage et la restauration
simultanée des 42000 m² des murs
intérieurs de la cathédrale grand
vaisseau collatéraux déambulatoire ainsi
que l'ensemble des 24 chapelles que
compte l'édifice sont bien avancés
l'échafaudage du transept sud dont les
restaurations sont terminées et en cours
et démontées en avance sur le calendrier
initial ce qui veut dire que le
transceptude est terminé nous sommes
dans la phase que tout le monde découvre
le 8 décembre
2024 au son de l'orgue retrouvé
donc en avant la restauration en cours
des nombreux décors peintures mural
ferronneries menuiserie vitraux des
chapelles et des tribunes sculptures
ainsi que des chefs-d'œuvre abrité par
la cathédrale
épargnés par l'incendie telle la clôture
du coeur les sculptures gothiques datant
du 14e siècle
tout cela retrouve sa beauté et sa
richesse et ajouter à la blondeur
retrouver des pierres tout cela
contribue à redonner à cette cathédrale
toute sa splendeur
enfin un dernier sujet auquel je suis
très attaché comme aux autres d'ailleurs
que je suis tout particulièrement les
travaux de remontage du Grand or dans la
cathédrale ont démarré cette semaine ça
veut dire que nous voyons revenir sur
l'île de la Cité les 8000 tuyaux que
nous avions démontés et les souffler que
nous avions envoyés ces trois facteurs
d'orgue en Corrèze dans le Vaucluse et
dans l'Hérault
donc
l'activité plus intense à l'intérieur de
la cathédrale et mobilise le nombre de
compagnons qui approchent aujourd'hui
les 400 nous allons arriver à 500
compagnons par jour sur la cathédrale ce
qui pose une série de problèmes
notamment avec les douches aussi bizarre
que cela puisse vous paraître
mais au total si l'on compte tous les
gens qui en France chez les mitraillés
chez les facteurs d'or dans les séries
qui préparent les chaînes etc et puis
nous tous qui travaillons pour cela
c'est plus de 1000 personnes qui sont à
l'oeuvre partout en France pour ce
chantier de restauration
je voudrais maintenant compléter cette
introduction en évoquant quelques sujets
dont il me semble important que votre
Commission soit informée il concerne les
relations que nous entretenons avec nos
différents partenaires dans nos
partenaires monsieur le Président vous
n'avez pas si le partenaire essentiel
qui est le dieu 16 bien évidemment
l'affectateur actuelle à la cathédrale à
travers donc son marché avec Monseigneur
Laurent
Ulrich
je note au passage que j'en suis depuis
le début de ce chantier à ma troisième
ministre et à mon troisième archevêque
mais je suis toujours là
donc
avec qui j'ai donc noué d'excellente
relation des sa domination
il est intéressant de noter que dès
qu'il arrive à Paris garde du Nord
venant de Lille il prend tout de suite
la direction de la cathédrale dans la
visite qu'il avait faite avant son
installation et il ne manque pas dans
ses interventions de montrer à quel
point dans son mandat d'archevêque de
Paris la restauration de la cathédrale
au-delà du monument est un poids
essentiel
donc il se mobilise avec ces gens pour
la réouverture de 2024 vous savez que le
diocèse est responsable de l'aménagement
liturgique de la cathédrale ce n'est pas
moi de définir évidemment les Allemands
liturgiques je ne suis là pour assurer
la cohérence de l'ensemble et le respect
du calendrier
c'est travaux d'aménagement et
évidemment viennent s'interfacer avec le
chantier que le qui est mené sous la
responsabilité de mon établissement
un document précis de limite de
prestation entre ces deux chantiers
étaient élaborés et il a fait l'objet
d'une présentation au Conseil
d'Administration de l'établissement
dans ce cadre l'archevêque de Paris a
engagé des consultations en octobre 2022
qui vont lui permettre de sélectionner
qui lui ont permis déjà de sélectionner
les artistes à qui confiera la
conception et la réalisation du futur
mobilier liturgique c'est-à-dire le
baptistère l'embon la cataire l'hôtel Le
tabernac et le reliquaire de la couronne
d'épines qui seront confiées à un même
artiste moderne
et évidemment aussi la question des
chaises nécessaires à la reprise du
culte il y a eu de nombreuses polémiques
sur les banques connectées etc les bancs
sont morts et les chaises viendront
c'est pas moi ça c'est
voilà alors il y a donc là dessus un
comité artistique qui conseille
l'archevêque et qui est évidemment réuni
en place plus de personnalités
qualifiées des représentants du diocèse
du ministre de l'acte du ministère de la
Culture et de l'établissement public
à noter également l'arrivée d'un nouveau
recteur à Chipettes de la cathédrale
donc là il y en aura eu que deux pour le
moment Monseigneur Olivier ribado Dumas
qui lui aussi a immédiatement pris à
bras le corps tous ces sujets et avec
lequel nous travaillons bien sûr de
manière efficace
la ville de Paris ensuite elle est un
partenaire important puisqu'elle est
responsable du projet d'aménagement des
abords de la cathédrale
elle n'a pas souhaité déléguer cette
opération à l'établissement comme la loi
votre loi le permettait elle a su donc
la maîtrise d'ouvrage ainsi que le
financement opération et qui permettra
d'installer la cathédrale restaurée dans
un écrin digne d'elle
nous avons disposé tout comme le diocèse
d'une place dans le jury créé par la
ville dans le cas de la procédure de
dialogue compétitif qu'elle a mis en
place et qui a permis de retenir
l'équipe menée par le paysagiste
bassemef afin de réaliser le projet
d'aménagement des abords
et la d'établissement public a participé
aux commissions techniques de ce
dialogue constitutif qui a contribué qui
a débuté sur ce résultat
donc nous avons d'excellents de bonnes
relations avec les équipes de la ville
et tout cela est fluide et constructif
avec ces deux partenaires ainsi qu'avec
le ministère de la Culture la Direction
Générale des Affaires Culturelles
d'Île-de-France et le Centre des
monuments nationaux qui gèrent le
circuit de visite des tours de la
cathédrale nous travaillons ensemble à
définition des conditions de réouverture
de la cathédrale c'est pas simple et mon
objectif dans le cas de la restauration
et de livrer un édifice apte bien sûr
occulte d'abord et au public
donc j'ai souhaité que puis cette
déterminée les conditions d'exploitation
de la cathédrale à l'échéance de sa
réouverture en 2024 cela passe c'est pas
simple cela passe par les le lancement
d'une étude confiée à une entreprise
spécialisée dans l'ingénierie de gestion
technique dont la mission est de
proposer en concertation avec toutes les
parties prenantes une organisation et un
cas de gestion d'exploitation et de
maintenant et de maintenant de la
cathédrale
nous avons également lancé une étude sur
les conditions provisoires liées à la
réouverture de la cathédrale en 2024
puisque tous ces travaux ne commenceront
qu'à partir de 2025 afin d'identifier et
promouvoir les aménagements nécessaires
je vais maintenant un plan important
puisqu'il nous est fixé aussi par la loi
les actions de mise en valeur du
chantier et des savoir-faire
nous poursuivons cette mission
comme en 2021 nous avons participé en
2022 à la 39e édition des Journées
européennes des patrimoines des 17 et 18
septembre en offrant aux visiteurs la
possibilité de découvrir un village du
chantier
les gens ont pu se fait maloriser avec
les différents métiers à l'oeuvre sur le
chantier avec plus de 20 000 visiteurs
sa dilution a été un succès le parvis
n'a pas des amplis de tout le week-end
plaçant de cette manifestation dans le
trio de tête au niveau de National de
l'Édition 2022 des Journées européennes
du patrimoine ce succès qui n'est pas
mince témoigne d'un intérêt du public
pour ce chantier qui ne se dément pas
et on a été très frappé par la précision
des questions qui ont été posées la
tension que les gens ont montré le
tourisme de base quoi c'était surtout
que c'était assez Harry
pour continuer à répondre pleinement à
cette attente et à cet intérêt nous
travaillons sur plusieurs domaines nous
avons un numéro
un journal qui s'appelle journal de la
fabrique qui est je vous le rappelle un
mécénat de LVMH et de connaissances des
arts qui a un succès considérable et
nous avons publié à la fin de l'année
dernière le numéro 4
les réseaux sociaux l'établissement
public Instagram Facebook LinkedIn
s'intensifie et
est assez suivi par nos followers nous
venons d'ouvrir également une chaîne
Youtube et l'ensemble des produits et
permet de faciliter la compréhension et
le suivi de ce chantier nous
coproduisons avec la kapale la cité de
la chutecture et du patrimoine une
exposition qui ouvrira le 15 février
inscrite parcours permanent de la Kapa
cette exposition s'intitule Notre-Dame
de Paris des bâtisseurs aux
restaurateurs sera l'occasion de
redécouvrir
la cathédrale et son histoire
enfin
une programmation culturelle complète et
ambitieuse sera proposé au public d'ici
début mars aux abords de la cathédrale
elle se articuleront 3 points une
exposition de photos renouvelées sur les
palissades de la cathédrale c'est un
mécénat de Jean-Charles Decaux ces
photos que nous avons installées dès le
début de des travaux dès le début de
l'examen de la République connaissent un
succès considérable
et ont apporté un peu d'apaisement aux
riverains et aux commerçants de la rue
du Cloître
nous allons mettre une borne Times SCOP
qui va être installée près du parvis
elle proposera en libre-service et de
façon gratuite la diffusion d'un film
bilingue de 3 minutes en réalité
virtuelle présentant le chantier enfin
nous avons inauguré hier soir sur la
cathédrale un espace sous le parking de
la Catane soul parvis pardon dans
l'ancien parking de la cathédrale un
espace qui s'appelle
[Musique]
un dispositif qui s'appelle espace de
Notre-Dame et qui
par grâce à Orange qui a financé la
réhabilitation du parking grâce à la
société à maclio propose un certain
nombre de
vision de réflexion sur le chantier dont
dont
l'expérience immersive en réalité
virtuelle internat de Notre-Dame qui a
été déjà proposé à la défense sur le
Toit de la Grande Arche et qui donc
s'installe maintenant sur le parvis de
la cathédrale jusqu'en 2024 si
Notre-Dame de Paris vous intéresse
vraiment je vous invite à aller visiter
cette exposition monsieur le Président
cela vous coûtera 30 euros mais je pense
que
et ça reviendra dans nos caisses
voilà nous allons nous compléter nos
dons nous avons inauguré ça hier soir et
nous allons compléter ça au mois de mars
nous établissements publics avec une
exposition que nous appelons au coeur du
chantier qui sera une véritable maison
du chantier et cette exposition
permettra à l'attente des nombreux
visiteurs qui seront dans la cathédrale
de s'informer elle offre un lieu
d'information gratuit elle rend
accessible chantier de la cathédrale et
enfin c'est une excellente occasion
finalement puisqu'on ne peut pas faire
rentrer le public dans la cathédrale par
des fils par des vidéos etc de lui
présenter tout ce que nous pouvons voilà
monsieur le Président tout ce que nous
faisons sans ménager ni notre temps ni
notre ardeur
ni notre enthousiasme
si général sans plus tarder on va
commencer les questions et c'est Sabine
Drexler notre rapporteur pour les
crédits patrimoine qui va commencer
pardon si je croyais avoir dit Sabine
mais il semblerait que je dis Céline
c'est bien Sabine évidemment
souci merci monsieur le Président alors
je vous je vous remercie pour votre
exposé qui était très complète pour le
travail accompli depuis plus de 3 ans
votre tâche est vraiment titanesque et
nous pouvons aujourd'hui vraiment nous
réjouir que les délais soient tenus
alors je vous ai écouté et j'ai lu aussi
avec attention le rapport de la Cour des
comptes d'octobre 2022 et j'aimerais
vous poser trois questions alors la
semaine dernière j'ai eu la chance de
découvrir le campus d'excellence de
Versailles qui propose des formations
métiers d'art qui sont des filières avec
de nombreux débouchés mais
malheureusement peu connu des jeunes et
dans lesquels nous connaissons une forte
pénurie en ressources humaines la
cathédrale est un chantier emblématique
qui fait appel à de nombreux artisans et
compagnons c'est une vitrine qui permet
de mettre en lumière ces métiers auprès
des jeunes aussi j'aimerais savoir si
vous avez mis des actions pour faire la
promotion en région de ces métiers d'art
et du patrimoine et c'est lui lesquels
deuxième question comment expliquer vous
le refus de mise en oeuvre de l'enquête
administrative sur les circonstances
dans lesquelles est survenue l'incendie
du 15 avril 2019
et troisième question votre
établissement fonctionne grâce au don
reçu du monde entier mais j'aimerais
savoir s'il est à contribué également
aux charges de fonctionnement de
l'établissement public si oui comment et
à quelle hauteur merci
trois questions et puis après je
donnerai la parole à d'autres sénateurs
pour la première question que vous avez
posée
la loi de juillet 2019 nous fait nous
donne la mission de développer en France
les métiers d'art etc
dans le contrat d'objectif et de
performance de l'établissement public il
est prévu la réalisation de
54000 heures d'insertion dans le cadre
des travaux de restauration de
Notre-Dame dont 40000 heures
d'apprentissage et nous avons dans les
lots que j'ai cité tout à l'heure que
nous avons sélectionné dans chacun des
appels d'offres que nous avons lancé
nous avons
[Musique]
déterminer les entreprises qui étaient
pertinentes pour réaliser ses heures de
formation et d'apprentissage et nous
nous sommes adjoints les services de
l'association Ensemble Paris emploi
compétences pour l'assister pronostic
dans l'élaboration et la réalisation de
cet objectif autrement dit l'objectif
d'apprentissage et de formation au
métier d'art et pris en compte et pris
en compte par les entreprises que nous
avons sélectionnées
que nous avons donc sélectionné pour
aller dans le sens madame la sénatrice
de votre question
mais compte tenu de la nature des
travaux vous avez compris qu'il y a une
phase de restauration consolidation qui
ne faisait pas à peine prioritairement
au métier d'art c'est maintenant dans la
phase
2023-2024 que l'essentiel de ces heures
d'apprentissage vont être réalisés
votre deuxième question madame la
sénatrice c'était le
fait qu'elle n'est pas eu lieu madame
poser cette question au ministre de la
Culture
très bien troisième question sur le fait
que l'État ne contribue pas aux charges
de fonctionnement ou uniquement pour la
prise en compte des loyers c'est un
débat récurrent depuis le début de cette
aventure le la réhabilitation la
restauration et la reconstruction de
Notre-Dame de Paris est assuré par une
souscription nationale cette
souscription nationale enfin
internationale d'ailleurs à remporté la
somme record de 846 millions d'euros
c'est 846 millions d'euros seront
nécessaires à la
réhabilitation de la cathédrale nous
avons dépensé 150 millions d'euros je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure pour la
phase de restauration consolidation nous
avons chiffré à l'heure actuelle contenu
des conditions actuelles de température
et de pression la phase de
reconstruction proprement dite à
552 millions d'euros il reste grosso
modo 146 millions d'euros cette somme
d'argent sera consacrée dans la phase
que nous appelons la phase 3 c'est à
dire à partir de 2025 à la restauration
des extérieurs de la cathédrale du
monument de la cathédrale l'État
participe après vos actions répétées
convergentes les plats participent à
l'établissement
comment dirais-je
en fonction du fonctionnement de
l'établissement public en payant notre
loyer de la cité Martignac et puis avec
les arrangements fiscaux que vous savez
voilà madame c'est tout c'était tout
merci j'en profite avant de donner la
parole à mes collègues ce que vous avez
donné des chiffres financiers je vous
remercie comme tout à l'heure vous avez
réagi quand j'ai parlé de surplus je
vais préciser ma pensée que vous
connaissez bien sûr et vous avez rappelé
les chiffres si on prend en compte les à
la fois les travaux déjà réalisés se
annoncés en tout cas budgétaire on est
effectivement sur 703 millions de de
travaux prévus et les dons on le sait
sont un peu moins de 850 millions
restent donc je simplifie les chiffres
pour la clarté du propos reste donc une
150 millions je précise également que
dans la prévision dans les travaux
prévisionnels des 550 millions il y a
des enveloppes importantes
de provision ce qui en souhaite une
bonne gestion mais on espère tous que
nous serons elles n'auront pas besoin
d'être sollicités mobilisés il y aura
donc effectivement à l'issue des travaux
de restauration
une partie des dons qui n'auront pas été
affectés alors vous dites qui pourront
être affectés à la poursuite des travaux
et notamment à ce qui était envisagé
avant l'incendie comme travaux de fond
sur Notre-Dame vous avez vous avez
précisé vous avez précisé vous avez vu
passer trois ministres de la Culture
nous aussi on en a dû passer un certain
nombre et on n'a pas oublié que un des
ministres de la Culture enfin que l'État
s'était engagé à affecter 60 millions de
crédit à la rénovation de notre Adam
avant bien entendu l'incendie et donc
nos interrogations qui sont des
interrogations légitimes visent à
veiller à ce que la rénovation de
Notre-Dame en dehors de des effets
catastrophiques de l'incendie ne soit
pas entièrement enfin en tout cas que
l'ét
conserve son engagement d'affecter 60
millions ou pour le moins s'ils ne sont
pas affectés à Notre-Dame qui soit
affecté à d'autres éléments de
patrimoine c'était le sens de notre
marque sur le surplus
alors bon c'est un débat ça va ça va
être le débat
financier les années qui viennent nous
avons eu le débat sur la partie version
de l'État dans la première phase nous
allons maintenant avoir celui de la
phase 3 que vous voulez le rappeler
monsieur le Président
que tel ou tel président de de fondation
agite régulièrement nous nous
reconstruisons la cathédrale Notre-Dame
de Paris vous n'imaginez pas un instant
vous ne pouvez pas imaginer un instant
et les donateurs ne peuvent pas imaginer
un instant que nous ne reconstruisions
et nous ne rétablissions cette
cathédrale de manière définitive à
définitive pour les siècles qui viennent
en tout cas et que nous rendions
[Musique]
sous prétexte que le culte sera réouvert
en 2024
la cathédrale avec ses arboutons à
refaire je vous rappelle que la
cathédrale c'est 28 arboutant
violer le duc à changer 28 arboutant
depuis violer le duc on a changé une
fois les 28 arbres boutons c'est un
chantier permanent cette cathédrale et
là les architectes nous disent que
fragilisés par l'incendie etc il y a une
dizaine d'arbitants de changer on va pas
attendre je ne sais quoi pour les
rechanger il y a des pierres à refaire
sur la face sur les élévations sud de la
cathédrale il y a des pierres à refaire
sur la tour sud la tour Nord avait été
refaite avant il y a le chevet l'autre
jour nous avons une superbe terrasse
monsieur le Président dans notre base de
vie qui domine le chevet de la
cathédrale c'est là que le Président de
la République a reçu lundi dernier le
Premier ministre japonais pour lui
montrer l'état de la cathédrale nous on
imaginez pas que l'on ne restaure pas
tout cela et bien c'est 146 millions
d'euros seront utilisés pour cela mais
cela sera fait évidemment en pleine
accord avec les fondations
nous les rencontrons régulièrement nous
nous mettons d'accord nous ferons un
plan et je ne doute pas que passer les
débats nécessaires dans une démocratie
Mature Active généreuse je ne doute pas
qu'à l'issue tout ceci se passera bien
et nous retrouverons et nous serons
fiers de cette cathédrale rénovée et je
suis convaincu que c'est la vie des
donateurs et en tout cas j'ai rencontré
les plus les plus généreux ces donateurs
et ils sont tous je dis bien tous sur
cette ligne
alors nous allons prendre une série de
questions en général si vous voulez bien
pierre ouzouyas en commençant pierre
ouzouglia Monique de Marco Sonia de la
pauvreté Céline Boulle espéronier
Marie-Pierre Monnier chaque groupe
Perrin et Laurence Garnier merci
monsieur le Président bonjour monsieur
le Président bonjour monsieur le général
plusieurs plusieurs points d'abord vous
l'avez dit il y a un esprit de travail
qui est tout à fait exemplaire et que
tous les les corps qui qui s'appliquent
à restaurer la cathédrale forme une
entité qui est complètement dévouée sur
l'objectif et moi je voudrais ici
rappeler l'énorme travail de
l'architecte en chef Monsieur Philippe
Villeneuve qui vit son monument tous les
jours tous les jours et dont
l'investissement est absolument
admirable et c'est lui un peu comme un
mortier entre les pierres qui fait cette
liaison avec tous les corps qui qui
interviennent je crois que
ce que sera le monument par la suite lui
devra beaucoup un petit peu comme comme
violet duc à apporter sa pierre à
l'édifice de la cathédrale moi je
voudrais
et vous en douter
et je voudrais intervenir sur
l'archéologie un sujet qui m'est cher
pour dire d'abord que tout le travail
s'agissant de l'archéologie a été fait
de façon exemplaire et je pense qu'il
lui était de très mauvaise politique que
l'État s'affranchit de ses obligations
en cette matière et à chaque fois qu'il
y a eu des travaux archéologiques à
faire vous les avez fait sans sans aucun
problème mais au cours de ces travaux on
a vu surgir le passé de la cathédrale
c'est-à-dire tous ces édifices
antérieurs qui remonte à la surface et
qui montre que Notre-Dame c'est
l'édifice actuels qu'on connaît aussi
mais c'est tous les édifices depuis le
4e siècle après Jésus-Christ voilà et
vous savez mon général que j'ai un petit
regret c'est que dans le cadre de ces
travaux il n'est pas été permis de
réaliser quelques sondages pour tester
les hypothèses sur la la présence de la
basilique Saint-Étienne qui se
trouverait
dans la nef près du portail d'entrée
parce que quand l'édifice sera rendu au
culte ses investigations archéologiques
ne seront plus possibles pour plusieurs
siècles de nouveau et j'ai bien compris
dans votre dans votre propos qui avait
une interpénétration de vos travaux qui
sont parfaitement définis par une
mission qui est très claire mais
d'autres par exemple vous l'avez vous
l'avez dit pour les travaux liés à
l'aménagement liturgique à l'aménagement
des circuits de visite donc pourquoi on
ne pourrait pas imaginer que puisque
toute façon il y a aujourd'hui des
travaux qui vont être commencés pour des
usages postérieurs après la livraison du
bâtiment pourquoi on pourrait pas
imaginer qui puisse y avoir une campagne
de sondage électrique par exemple
non non destructeurs qui permettre de
restituer toute l'histoire de la
cathédrale du 4e siècle jusqu'à jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et jusqu'à Philippe
Villeneuve en tant que consommateur de
l'oeuvre de Violetta merci monsieur le
Président Monique de Marco
je vous remercie monsieur le général je
vous remercie pour votre exposé clair et
vos réponses souvent précises moi je
reviendrai sur l'exemplarité
vous en avez parlé et surtout celle de
l'utilisation du plan prévue pour la
nation donc de la toiture et de la
flèche
certes le plan peut avoir une
interchitecturale car il est malléable
et il est vrai que la Commission
Nationale d'Architecture du patrimoine à
réviser l'établissement public de
restaurer à l'identique la cathédrale
choix qui a été validé par le Président
de la République
l'esthétique imprimé sur la santé en
particulier celle des enfants car le
plan est un matériau toxique et la
maladie dit le saturisme est toujours
d'actualité aussi mes questions sont
j'en ai trois quelles sont les éléments
scientifiques d'expertise sanitaire sur
lesquelles se basent la décision de
restauration avec du plomb
deuxième question Quels sont les
dispositifs de prévention de pollution
au plomb mis en place sur le chantier et
après et ensuite attendez-vous les
résultats de l'étude prévue pour
installer 300 tonnes de plans sur un
lieu touristique fréquenté par de
nombreux enfants
je vous remercie
Sonia de la propreté
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci pour cette présentation comme à
chaque fois extrêmement complète et qui
nous permet au travers de ces rencontres
régulières de faire un état des lieux de
l'avancement de ce chantier qui nous
tient tous évidemment à coeur vient de
là bien au-delà de nos frontières et
donc remercier
l'établissement public et l'architecte
en chef pour pour voilà cette
contribution efficace et é proactive à
nous redonner Notre-Dame dans sa gloire
moi j'ai quelques questions qui sont
finalement issues des deux rapports de
de la Cour des comptes le premier vous
savez bien que depuis le début et depuis
les discussions du texte de loi il y a
vraiment des sujets de transparence et
et c'est ces auditions là sont
évidemment l'occasion de pouvoir
répondre à ces problématiques de
transparence est-ce que en ce qui
concerne le le fonctionnement
d'établissement public est-ce que une
comptabilité analytique accessible à
tous a été mise en place
puisque évidemment c'était un des sujets
et et d'ailleurs vous venez de répondre
sur la contribution du fonctionnement de
l'État au travers du loyer j'imagine
bien que cette comment dire cette
comptabilité ne se résume pas au loyer
de de
d'hébergement de l'établissement public
et donc pouvons-nous avoir ces éléments
en l'état actuel des choses il y avait
un désir de récollement complet des
objets
liturgiques et et non liturgique tu
restes de Notre Dame et et un état des
lieux en matière de de budget de
calendrier de des restaurations
nécessaires est-ce que cette ce
catalogue ce calendrier le budget ont
été mis en place puisque ça faisait
partie des demandes et on sait que que
les objets liturgiques et non
liturgiques d'intérêt au sein de
Notre-Dame sont évidemment essentielles
pour pour notre histoire
la troisième question vous y avez
répondu concernés la question des abords
et de la participation finalement de de
l'établissement public
au projet d'aménagement des abords du
parvis et puis de de des quais de scène
est-ce qu'il est est-ce qu'il est prévu
en dehors de cette participation de
choix dans l'équipe qui déjà était un
élément absolument essentiel et majeur
est-ce qu'il est prévu une
co-participation
financière sur en dehors de comment dire
des restaurations nécessaires des murs
de Notre-Dame est-ce qu'il est prévu
quand même sur les abords de très grande
proximité mais qui sont quand même
finalement quelque part
complètement liés à Notre-Dame est-ce
qu'il est prévu une participation de
l'établissement public
assez travaux et puis ma dernière
question porte sur
sur ce qu'a évoqué le président Lafont
justement c'est effectivement il y aura
des reliquats puisqu'il y a eu des
réserves de mise en œuvre et d'ailleurs
c'est l'occasion de féliciter quand même
la bonne tenue budgétaire des travaux
parce que en ces temps un peu compliqué
on peut quand même le le signaler bon
des réserves importantes ont été mises
ont été prévus et on voit bien que mi
bout à bout
ce que vous évoquez comme étant les
travaux nécessaires qui relevaient de 60
millions d'euros de crédit de l'État au
départ qu'il a compte tenu de ce qui
s'est passé risque d'être plus important
est-ce que quand même les 146 millions +
les réserves
inévitablement qui vont qui vont grossir
cette enveloppe est-ce que un reliquat
est-ce qu'il ne serait pas utile
d'envisager dès à présent un usage du
reliquat autre que celui strictement de
Notre-Dame
on continue avec Céline Boulley
monsieur le Président et merci général
pour cette présentation vous avez bien
évidemment devancé un certain nombre de
nos questions notamment en matière
financière j'ai bien retenu et compris
tout ce qui avait été organisé sur le
parvis et on peut que féliciter de
l'intérêt des Parisiens et des Français
pour ce qui est organisé notamment le
chantier j'ai beaucoup plus de réserves
sur la survie des commerçants et des
bouquinistes en espérant que ils
survivront tous d'ici 2024 et ma
question est la suivante pour aller plus
loin
dans le sens de la question de ma
collègue Sabine Draxler sur l'incendie
dont on sait qu'évidemment l'enquête
administrative n'a pas conclu à 100% ce
qui s'était passé je voudrais tout de
même savoir si cela aurait fait
jurisprudence ici des dispositions
particulières ont été mises en oeuvre
pour éviter que cela ne se reproduise
notamment sur les fameuses échafaudages
dans l'un de 300 tonnes qui sont très
conséquents et au moins que ça ait quand
même pu servir à quelque chose même si
nous savons tous que le risque zéro
n'existe pas je vous remercie
Marie pierrotier
président double merci aussi pour avoir
organisé cette audition parce que ça
fait partie de notre rôle de
parlementaire de contrôler l'action du
Gouvernement sur un texte dont nous
avons d'ailleurs été saisi au fond sur
la Commission et j'espère continuera le
faire puisque le chantier va encore
durer quelques années moi je reprendrai
un petit peu ce qu'a dit Sonia de la
pauvreté j'aurais bien aimé aussi savoir
comment est-ce qu'on peut être au
courant vraiment au jour le jour mais en
tout cas un état des lieux précis de la
consommation des crédits ils sont en
particulier de la souscription nationale
parce que
Sonia a parlé vous l'avez dit qu'il y
avait un petit surplus mais qui serait
utilisé moi je rencontre des artisans
chez moi qui me disent que l'écoute des
matériaux ont pris des hausses allant
jusqu'à 20% je sais même pas si cette
semaine on m'a pas parlé de 30 ou 40%
donc j'imagine que sur un chantier de
cette ampleur cela aura de des
conséquences importantes quand tout à
l'heure vous avez parlé des 1846
millions de surplus vous avez parlé de
redorer la cathédrale ça ça m'interpelle
un petit peu parce que pour moi les dons
ça fait partie de reconstruire ce qui a
été détruit est-ce que vous envisagez
des travaux d'entretien qui pour moi ne
sont pas utilisés enfin ne doivent pas
être financés par les dons mais par
l'État le diocèse vous avez dit que
c'était un partenaire essentiel à quel
niveau est-ce que financièrement y
participent à l'achat par exemple de
matériel liturgiques ou pas comment j'ai
bien compris que c'était un partenaire
pour suivre les travaux mais voilà
j'avais lu qu'il y avait je crois mise à
jour par l'INRAP de cercueil entre on
pour morphe qui ont été
trouvés l'un avait été identifié est-ce
que l'autre l'a été et est-ce qu'il y a
eu d'autres découvertes dans le chantier
je vous remercie
chaque gros Perrin
si président merci général pour ces
explications moi j'aurais
j'ai tendance à dire souvent que le
temps médiatique n'est pas le temps
politique et on voit bien que c'était un
sujet en même temps politique ce cette
restauration de Notre-Dame les enjeux
ont été fort bien dit tout à l'heure et
la Cour des comptes les avaient bien
exprimé sur les recommandations sur la
comptabilité analytique donc parler
Sonia de la Pro BT et également sur la
subvention annuelle si on sort un petit
peu de de ces problèmes de financement
moi je voudrais avoir quelques quelques
réponses par rapport à ce qu'on appelle
l'humain et vous avez dit tout à l'heure
que l'inspection du travail est le
président la font la liberté était fort
présente pas simplement sur le travail
dissimulé mais ce que peut nous faire un
bilan peut-être aussi sur les accidents
qui a pu avoir je fais pas référence au
Qatar mais lorsqu'on parle de pays
étrangers parfois à la France on doit
aussi monter un trou tout à faire preuve
d'exemple la deuxième question mais je
suis pas trop inquiet mais souvent
on se rend compte c'est arrivé le 15
avril 2019 nous sommes au 4/5 en réalité
du moment de l'ouverture ça fait quatre
ans est-ce que le fait de travailler
très vite je pense que
Pierre rouselier a dit tout à l'heure
aussi sous le léger du site de
l'architecte monsieur Villeneuve des
bâtiments de France bien sûr avec votre
votre expertise aussi en tout cas de
coordination je crois qu'il était il est
important de d'être prudent sur la
vitesse et la précipitation à savoir la
continuité comment ça peut durer dans le
temps parce que c'est vrai que d'aller
très vite à un moment donné on peut
s'interroger aussi à travers vous nous
avez dit tout à l'heure qu'il y avait
500 compagnons par jour donc ça veut
dire aussi qu'il y a une expertise et
enfin une dernière question j'ai pas pu
participer aux dernières
auditions le covid est-ce que vous êtes
sorti est-ce qu'il y avait eu quelque
chose par rapport au covid si vous êtes
sortis de justement de cette
réglementation de ces confinement où
est-ce que les les compagnons tous ceux
qui ont participé à la restauration de
Notre-Dame ont été un moment donné
confinés ou est-ce que les travaux ont
continué à cette période là même si
cette question a pu être posée dans
l'ordre de les dernières auditions
Laurence Garnier et leur Arcos
oui merci monsieur le Président merci
général pour les précisions que vous
avez apportées je voudrais dans le
prolongement de mes collègues Céline
voulait esperoni et Sabine Dressler
revenir sur le retour d'expérience qui
pourra être fait de de l'incendie que
nous avons connu alors moi je suis
sénatrice de la Loire-Atlantique vous
savez qu'à Nantes nous avons connu
quelques mois après l'incendie de la
cathédrale Notre-Dame de Paris celui de
la cathédrale de Nantes pour des raisons
toutes différentes bien sûr que chacun
ici à l'esprit mais la cathédrale avait
brûlé pour des raisons accidentelles en
1972 et nous avons aussi eu à Nantes
l'incendie de la basilique
Saint-Donatien en 2015 donc vous voyez
que nous avons été particulièrement
touchés par ces incendies liées à des
travaux dans les toitures de nos
édifices religieux donc je voulais
savoir à côté du chantier de
restauration lui-même comment vous
travaillez au process de sécurisation et
de du risque incendie dans nos édifices
religieux et s'il y avait des réflexions
communes qui étaient conduites
au niveau régional et nationale pour
mettre en commun les retours
d'expérience de ces différents incendies
survenus au cours des dernières années
merci beaucoup président
général je j'arrive un petit peu en
retard mais je crois que vous n'avez pas
évoqué je trouve que ça aurait été
intéressant pour mes collègues la
restauration des 14 toiles de mètres qui
sont actuellement en cours dans mon
département d'Essonne j'ai eu la chance
avec la ministre de pouvoir les voir et
je sais que malheureusement tout le
monde ne pourra pas le faire mais ce
sont tous les plus beaux tableaux de
Notre-Dame qui sont en train d'être
restaurés et qui seront bien sûr
réacrochés avant l'ouverture si vous
pouviez nous en dire un petit mot
voilà
merci monsieur le président
tout le monde commence par dire merci
mon Général etc vous avez été très clair
etc oui de très bien élevé mais on vous
est en écoutant vos questions je vais le
sentiment que j'ai été vraiment de très
obscur et pas clair du tout parce que
beaucoup de vos questions reviennent sur
des choses
comment
bien madame bises
mais il faut quand même pas en abuser
dans le cas d'une commission qui dure
deux heures voilà alors je ne sais pas
par quoi commencer je vais commencer par
les tableaux de madame la sénatrice
darkos
il y a évidemment des travaux de
restauration des des
œuvres d'art qui sont liées
essentiellement d'ailleurs à la
poussière de plomb qui s'est répandue
dans la cathédrale après l'incendie et
donc 22 grands formats de la cathédrale
ont été envoyés dans un endroit secret
madame sénatrice pour que les hordes
terrorisme puissent venir les détruire
et ils sont actuellement restaurés de
manière absolument spectaculaire et on
redécouvre la beauté de s'aimer vous
savez ce que c'est que les mets les
tableaux qui étaient offerts chaque 1er
mai à la cathédrale entre 1737 et en 16
1737 non 1637 et 1737 et c'est une
véritable
résurrection en particulier une activité
de l'onun devant laquelle vous avez dû
passer 25 fois à chaque fois que vous
êtes passé dans la cathédrale sans vous
réalisez une seule seconde c'était un
travail de Lena nous allons retrouver de
la même manière que nous allons
retrouver la splendeur des pierres la
splendeur des peintures des chapelles
nous allons retrouver la lumière de ces
tableaux voilà merci madame la sénatrice
de m'avoir donné l'occasion de se lancer
travaux sont évidemment restauration
dues à l'incendie financée par la
souscription nationale
nous avons eu une question par vous
madame la sénatrice sur l'utilisation du
plomb dans la cathédrale mais avant ça
je vais répondre à une partie de la
question de monsieur le sénateur
nous avons eu parce que c'est lié à la
vôtre madame
vous m'avez interrogé sur l'état
sanitaire en quelque sorte de métroupe
nous avons eu en toute et pour tout sur
ce chantier et il faut le souligner une
fracture d'un tibia d'un malheureux
compagnon qui qui malencontreusement
tombé sur le chantier c'est tout nous
n'avons eu aucun accident alors c'est
bien évidemment lié à la comment
dirais-je l'intérêt tout à fait précis
bienveillant
bénéfique exemplaire
utile de l'inspection du travail et la
manière dont nous respectons toutes les
règles du corps du travail de la même
manière madame la sénatrice nous nous
contrôlons régulièrement nos compagnons
et nous puisque nous allons sur le
chantier
au regard des plombs émis possibles si
tenter que ça a un sens car vous savez
mieux que moi Madame que la progression
est extrêmement lente et compliquée et
nous n'avons par rapport au plomb
rigoureusement strictement aucun indice
de quoi que ce soit voilà alors j'en
viens au plomb madame le plomb il y a
deux sujets il y a le sujet du plan
résiduel de l'incendie et il y a le
sujet de l'utilisation du plomb pour la
restauration de la cathédrale
s'agissant du premier point là aussi
sous l'effet
salutaires évidemment de Madame Rambaud
inspective du travail dédié à la
cathédrale le respect admirable que nous
faisons moi le premier des conditions
des options à prendre pour le plomb vous
savez que j'ai été chef d'état-major des
armées je suis allé dans les usines de
préparation de nos armements du clair ce
qu'on exigeait de nous en tel secrétaire
il n'a rien à voir avec ce que l'on
demande pour pénétrer sur le chantier de
la cathédrale quand le président de la
République vient à la cathédrale comme
le compagnon de base il perçoit ses
bottes et moi tous les jours ça ça
combinaison
ces sous-vêtements ces sous-vêtements
son casque il va nous allons sur la zone
dite sale le terme en soi déjà n'est pas
neutre
nous faisons ce que nous avons à faire
sur la cathédrale nous nous revenons
nous nous dénudons complètement
nous prenons une douche et nous
récupérons nos affaires vous me
permettrez comment
il y a eu des refus là-dessus voilà donc
nous réfléchissons et nous n'avons
strictement aucune incident alors vous
parlez des enfants nous ne voyons pas
d'enfants sur le chantier de la
cathédrale le deuxième sujet que vous
avez soulevé c'est le choix du plomb et
dans votre question vous avez laissé
sous-entendre madame la sénatrice que
cette question avait été cette sujet
avait été pris de manière légère mais
elle a été prise conformément
aux règles de la rénovation des
monuments historiques en France c'est à
dire qu'il y a un organisme qui
s'appelle la CNPA la Commission
nationale du patrimoine et
l'architecture qui émet un avis sur la
base des études qu'elle fait et qui a
donc donné
donner son avis favorable à la
reconstruction en plomb pour des raisons
que vous avez rapidement évoqué
malléabilité etc etc etc documents de
musique etc mais nous sommes là madame
alors j'insiste sur le fait que le plomb
ce sera la couverture du Grand comble et
la flèche
vous avez parlé des enfants je reçois
des lettres absolument extraordinaires
nous ne verrons jamais un enfant allait
se promener sur le grand comble nous ne
verrons jamais un enfant allait lécher
le les plaques de plomb mis sur les
chaînes qui reconstituent la flèche
autrement dit ce risque là est très
exactement égal à 0
le risque résiduel de l'emploi du plomb
sur la couverture du Grand comble et la
flèche est liée aux eaux de
ruissellement
nous allons être des précurseurs
absolument géniaux en matière de
d'analyse des eaux de ruissellement nous
allons mettre en place un dispositif qui
à travers les 104 commerciaux
de monsieur le sénateur nous allons donc
récupérer par les gags toutes les eaux
de pluie dans des dispositifs que nous
allons mettre au sol et nous allons les
analyser pour voir le plomb qu'elle
contienne avant de les reverser dans la
scène nous sommes véritablement
exemplaires ça n'a jamais été fait donc
soyez rassurés aucun enfant de France
n'aura de plomberies en raison de la
reconstruction du plomb en plomb de
notre âme de Paris j'ajoute que
[Musique]
au début quand j'étais nommé dans cette
fonction je disais je suis commandant la
tasse force Notre-Dame etc en réalité je
ne me lasse jamais et j'en viens
d'ailleurs aux nombreuses questions qui
m'ont été posées sur le contrôle de nos
dépenses je ne sais plus quel sénatrice
inspirait nous expliquer qu'on avait
aucune visibilité sur la manière dont
nous coûts étaient etc je vais vous
lister le nombre d'organismes on ne peut
pas bouger un petit doigt sans que 25
personnes viennent contrôler ce que nous
faisons donc j'ai fait cette dégression
pourquoi rappelez-moi
oui alors ce n'est pas moi qui signe les
ce n'est pas moi qui signe les
autorisations de travaux
comme pour tout monument historique
c'est le préfet d'Île-de-France patron
de la drague
vous imaginez pas
l'intérêt le travail précis avec lequel
le préfet a contrôler tout ce qui avait
très à la à la à l'utilisation du plomb
sur la cathédrale le document qu'il a
signé est un véritable chef-d'oeuvre de
droit administratif qui prend en compte
tout ce qu'il est possible de prendre en
compte pour s'entourer de toutes les
mesures de précaution possible et
imaginables madame la sénatrice je ne
vois pas en dehors de renoncer au plomb
bien évidemment pourquoi ça reste à
définir je ne vois pas en quoi
l'utilisation du plomb dans la
reconstruction de notre âme de Paris
puisse pour faire poser le moindre
danger que ce soit sur les enfants
j'ajoute que conformément à la
législation française le
[Musique]
le décret c'est un décret de variation
de travaux a été affichée sur nos murs
pendant deux ans pendant deux mois nous
avons atteint pendant d'avoir attendu
tous les jours de voir si on a les
contester personne n'a contesté
l'utilisation du plomb je crois qu'il
faut aussi c'est bien de discuter etc
mais je crois aussi qu'il faut d'abord
faire preuve d'humilité dans ces
questions à te mettre qu'on n'a pas de
soi seul la vérité sur les choses et une
fois qui est décisions est prise avec
toutes les instances qui caractérisent
notre pays et bien on a on l'accepte et
on puisse aller de l'avant sinon nous
mettrions évidemment 50 ans à
reconstruire la cathédrale Notre-Dame de
Paris alors je reviens maintenant aux
questions si j'ai bien compris
[Musique]
on avait déjà eu des observations sur la
comptabilité analytique précédemment
c'est doté des outils nécessaires à une
comptabilité analytique
je précise aussi que nous avons parmi
les parmi les
les
[Musique]
gens qui nous contrôlent sur le final
sur les plans financiers et la manière
dont nous informons nos partenaires nous
avons d'abord un comité des donateurs
auquel nous présentons tout ce que nous
faisons et auquel nous expliquons tout
ce que nous prévoyons de faire nous
avons ensuite un
comité d'audit un comité d'audit prévu
par la loi d'ailleurs
présidé par Monsieur Weiss qui est un
ancien
ingénieur et un ancien directeur général
du patrimoine qui nous fait aucun cadeau
qui vérifie la légitimité de toutes les
demandes de travaux que nous présentons
au ministère de la Culture pour recevoir
les fonds nécessaires venant de la
souscription à nos travaux nous avons un
comité spécifique
composé des présidents des commissions
des affaires culturelles et des Finances
de l'Assemblée nationale du Sénat qui se
réunissent sous la présidence de la Cour
des comptes du
le monsieur le Premier Président de la
Cour des comptes et qui est là aussi
pour vérifier que nous ne faisons pas
n'importe quoi nous avons comme tout
établissement public un conseil
d'administration qui autorise et qui
votent les doigts donc si vous voulez
[Musique]
pareil d'ailleurs tout à fait légitime à
retirer elle avait annoncé qu'elle
mettrait 50 millions d'euros elle
proposait 50 millions d'euros je crois
que c'est le bon chiffre pour la
souscription et la retirer et les a dit
je les affecte aux abords ça me paraît
ça paraît tout à fait légitime
il y a une question aussi si j'ai bien
compris sur le financement des
aménagements intérieurs c'est vous
madame la silatrice les
pardon le financement
tous les objets d'art intérieur et tout
ce qui touche à l'aménagement liturgique
de la cathédrale
[Musique]
comment dirais-je
et financer par le diocèse de Paris
l'État ne met pas un euro dans le
financement de l'hôtel du baptistère de
la catène etc etc la loi de 1905 madame
et parfaitement respecté
voilà par le biais de la
Fondation Notre-Dame qui reçoit
d'ailleurs qui reçoit d'ailleurs des
dons pour ça il y a vous avez la
Fondation vous avez beaucoup de
fondations autour de Notre-Dame qui
participent au financement des
aménagements liturgiques qu'est-ce qu'il
y a d'autre
retour d'expérience une incendie
[Musique]
j'ai parlé du plomb des eaux de
ruissellement etc de la même manière
qu'on nous a expliqué vous allez tuer
tous les enfants de France on nous a dit
aussi n'ont pas vous madame pas vous
mais voyez pas tout ce que je reçois si
vous voulez vous ne voyez vous ne voyez
pas tout ce que je reçois
par rapport à ce chantier c'est parce
que vous avez dit vous bien sûr mais
alors vous avez on nous dit aussi
pourquoi refaire en bois alors que vous
avez eu un incendie donc on n'est pas
complètement idiot tout ceci a été a été
traité et nous avons pour la protection
incendie prix un certain nombre de
mesures d'abord nous avons réduit la
présence de l'électricité dans les
combles parmi les hypothèses de
l'incendie il y a celui d'un
court-circuit dans dans les combles nous
avons nous allons mettre en place un
système de détection de fumée par
aspiration nous allons mettre dans les
combes ce qui n'existait pas avant des
parois coupe-feu
nous allons redimensionner les colonnes
sèches alimentant les combles nous
allons enfin nous allons va être
installé c'est pas c'est pas les
logements publics bien sûr c'est les
parties prenantes de la cathédrale un
nouveau PC sécurité incendie qui sera
armé 24 heures sur 24 vous avez le droit
de vous interroger évidemment sur le
fait que ça aurait pu être peut-être
fait avant évidemment nous avons
avoir des pièces d'accès sécurisées à
proximité des charpentes pour les
pompiers en intervention
nous allons avoir une augmentation
Parrot Paris de l'alimentation en eau de
l'île de la Cité et surtout nous allons
installer un dispositif de brumisation
en vue de voilà nous allons rester un
dispositif de brumisation automatique
sur la charpente rénovée vous voyez nous
avons pris cette affaire à bras-le-corps
et voilà les mesures qui vont être mises
en œuvre
pour accompagner le choix du chêne pour
reconstruire la charpente
merci il y avait la dernière question
mais peut-être que ça n'appartient pas à
l'établissement public d'y répondre sur
la possibilité de poursuivre les
recherches archéologiques
alors s'agit
full archéologiques nous appliquons
strictement la loi et les fouilles qui
ont été faites à Notre-Dame de Paris par
ce chantier que dont je dessinais duquel
je préside
ont été faites sur des lieux qui
allaient être ouvert en raison du
chantier les fouilles sur le transept
qui sont des foudres d'archéologie
préventives et pas des fouilles
systématique pour retrouver les les les
cathédrales enfin les édifices des
premiers temps de l'art chrétien qui ont
déjà eu lieu d'ailleurs à la cathédrale
ont eu lieu donc sur le transept nous
avons découvert donc les restes du jubé
abattu au 18e siècle et
les femmes sarcophages
j'ai plus le chiffre en tête quoi c'est
400 c'est ça je crois qu'il y a 400
personnes enterré sous la cathédrale
donc comment
ouais mais tout le monde se faisait
enterrer à la cathédrale
bon bref là on a trouvé deux violets le
ducs n'avait d'ailleurs trouvé 8 avant
mais il n'avait pas trouvé les pierres
du Juppé donc tout ceci a été fait dans
les règles de la moi j'ai simplement
veillé à ce qu'on ne m'arrête pas le
chantier pendant un an pour trouver
d'autres d'autres
restes d'autres voilà donc j'ai exercé
mon autorité si bien que dans dans un
climat absolument parfait avec l'INRA
que je souligne nous avons fait ça en
bonne intelligence contrairement à ce
que j'ai pu lire dans la presse et
notamment dans Le Canard enchaîné
voilà et donc ça c'est bien fait il nous
en avons fait d'autres d'ailleurs donc
curieusement personne n'a parlé c'est
amusant parce que c'était sans doute
moins attractif pour les caméras et les
mises en valeur de tel ou tel nous avons
aussi fait des fous d'archéologie
préventive je l'ai dit rapidement d'une
phrase dans mon exposé tout à l'heure
nous devons creuser pour faire
l'alimentation des
idricités sous le parvis etc on a creusé
on a fouillé et on la refermé tout ceci
c'est bien fait je n'ai pas vu ça m'a
beaucoup amusé en réalité un seul
article là-dessus dans les médias
spécialisés ou non donc tout ceci nous
le faisons dans le respect complet des
règles auxquelles nous ne pouvons
évidemment pas échapper et auquel nous
n'avons pas d'ailleurs la moindre
comme on dit aller à moindre volonté
d'échapper
toute dernière question mais rapide
d'Alexandra donc
dans le micro parce que
qu'en fait je voulais juste se déplace
pas désolé donc on peut pas se voir vous
allez m'entendre je voulais juste en
fait saluer le la qualité de
l'expérience immersive qui est proposée
sur le parvis de Notre-Dame depuis hier
soir j'ai eu l'opportunité de de la
vivre lundi à Nice parce qu'il y a une
démonstration et j'invite en fait mes
collègues à se rendre donc c'est pendant
les travaux c'est une expérience qui
dure 45 minutes on est complètement
immergé dans les travaux de Notre-Dame
donc retour vers le futur ouvert le
passé enfin en tout cas c'est
époustouflant c'est troublant j'espère
que tous les Français pourront vivre
cette expérience y compris les enfants
parce que ça permet d'aller dans des
coins de la de Notre-Dame où on pourra
jamais aller et alors je crois que ça a
été lancé hier soir d'ailleurs en tout
cas c'est ouvert au public et c'est
vraiment incroyable donc j'espère que ça
pourra que vous pourrez continuer à le
diffuser après après les travaux et
surtout que ce soit diffusé ailleurs je
sais pas par quels moyens en tout cas
l'opérateur ou la synthèse qui a mis ça
en place c'est vraiment exceptionnel
c'est exceptionnel c'est donc un et une
société qui a fait ça nous l'avions il
l'avait présenté sur le Toit de la
Grande Arche 60
000 personnes sont venues le voir
là nous l'avons donc installé depuis
assez ouvert à partir d'aujourd'hui au
public sous le parvis de Notre-Dame sur
le l'ancien parking
quand on voit le monde qui vient monte
qui vient tous les jours pour voir le
chantier notre âme à travers l'extérieur
mais là je pense que tous ces gens là
descendront dans le
dans le parking et regarderont parce que
comme vous l'avez dit c'est pas
simplement visiter Notre-Dame c'est
toute l'histoire de la construction de
Notre-Dame comme si on y était
alors on normalement il est prévu de le
mettre là à sous le parvis
et si j'ai bien compris mais chose en
France sont parfois difficiles à suivre
je crois qu'après ça devrait aller à la
Conciergerie ou c'est ça quelque chose
comme ça voilà mais c'est un
chef-d'œuvre
30 euros madame
mais madame vous contribuerez au
financement
vous contribuerez au financement du
système de ruissellement des eaux de
pluie merci général et on va terminer
on va terminer ainsi sur cette sur ces
bonnes nouvelles notre commission
quelques secondes s'il vous plaît
d'abord pour vous remercier général
parce que comme je le rappelais tout à
l'heure
le une fois que vous venez et nous
sommes toujours très attachés à vous
écouter à vous poser des questions c'est
normal c'est notre rôle est
nous souhaitons comme vous même si nous
ne sommes là que pour contrôler mais
nous sommes souhaitons comme vous la
réussite bien sûr de ce chantier
exceptionnel et la réouverture de
Notre-Dame et je crois pouvoir dire au
nom de mes collègues que nous apprécions
vos auditions qui quelque part sont
assez uniques donc
[Rires]